[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue jérôme
durain pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre il règne dans ce pays une
atmosphère irrespirable vendredi en
séance du conseil régional de bourgogne
franche comté le président d'un groupe
qui n'a rien de républicain a fait
dégénérer les échanges en accusant
d'abord les agents de la région d'être
touché par la radicalisation et le
communautarisme islamistes en twittant
ensuite la perte d'appétit que provoque
chez lui une exposition consacrée à
martin luther king en m'agressant enfin
verbalement une femme voilée des enfants
venus découvrir les institutions
républicaines sont repartis dans le
tumulte et une maman accompagnatrice
sous la menace de l'arrivée des russes
certains ont vu dans ces événements une
interrogation sur la laïcité
j'y vois surtout la triste expression du
racisme que nous croyons au ciel ou que
nous n'y croyons pas nous avons la
responsabilité de dénoncer le climat
malsain qui règne dans ce pays les
musulmans pour ce qu'ils sont
sont pointés du doigt monsieur zemmour
récemment condamné a son rond de
serviette sur les plateaux de télévision
dans les universités des fichages
tendancieux commencent à apparaître
nous ne tomberons pas dans les pièges
tendus par les provocateurs de tous
bords notre boussole c'est la concorde
républicaine le président macron et vous
même monsieur le premier ministre avait
rappelé l'état du droit
en ce qui concerne la laïcité hier
encore 90 personnalités ont lancé un
appel au président pour condamner les
événements de vendredi
que comptez vous faire monsieur le
premier ministre pour endiguer la
libération de la parole raciste dans ce
pays
quand vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur une
nouvelle fois notre pays
cette assemblée notre société se
passionne et se divisent pour une
question en l'occurrence la question du
voile
je ne méconnais en rien l'importance de
ce sujet mais face à ses passions je me
permets de vous répondre monsieur le
sénateur que ma boussole à moi c'est le
droit et mon cap c'est la lutte contre
le communautarisme et la radicalisation
ma boussole monsieur le sénateur c'est
le droit et le droit
il est posé depuis longtemps
c'est l'article 10 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen c'est la
loi de 1905 qui prévoit vous le savez
nous le savons tous un double principe
extrêmement exigeant celui de la
neutralité absolue des pouvoirs publics
et des agents publics et celui de la
liberté de nos concitoyens à croire ou
ne pas croire et à exercer leur culte
dans le respect de la loi
ces principes ne sont pas des petites
choses
ils sont au coeur de la façon dont nous
avons choisi de vivre et nous y sommes
je le sais a tâché alors bien entendu
sur ces principes nous pouvons parfois
avoir des différences d'appréciation
nous avons déjà fait bouger le cadre
juridique
je sais vous savez que en 2004 le
parlement a choisi d'aller plus loin
s'agissant de la laïcité en indiquant
que le port de signes religieux
distinctifs là en l'occurrence du voile
et être interdit dans les enceintes
scolaires à l'école au collège et au
lycée
il l'a fait c'est la loi elle a été
jugée constitutionnelle c'est donc un
principe qui nous oblige mais cette loi
n'a pas dit que le voile était interdit
à l'université elle n'a pas dit que le
voile est interdit dans le cadre
des sorties scolaires lorsque des
parents lorsque des parents accompagner
bénévolement volontairement une sortie
scolaire
mesdames et messieurs c'est la loi et
c'est la jurisprudence constante et
rappeler est rappelé et monsieur le
président il me semble que rappeler la
loi de façon précise dans l'hémicycle au
sénat n'est pas quelque chose d'inutile
et n'est certainement pas quelque chose
de critiquable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce que la loi fait ce que la loi a
fait la loi peut le modifier dans le
respect de la constitution dans le
respect des principes
après un débat j'ai bien compris qu'un
certain nombre sur ses bancs en
l'occurrence porter l'idée d'une
modification de la loi le parlement aura
vocation à en débattre jeudi pour ma
part que la boussole ayant été expliqué
c'est le droit tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
le cap me semble devoir être celui de la
lutte contre la radicalisation contre le
communautarisme et il me semble et c'est
un avis personnel
il me semble qu'en matière de lutte
contre la radicalisation et le
communautarisme il y a des choses
incroyablement plus efficace à faire
incroyablement plus productive à faire
que de légiférer sur les sorties
scolaires et l'interdiction du voile
dans les sorties scolaires
je me permets là aussi d'exprimer ma
ligne il me semble qu'à la suite
d'ailleurs de ce qu' il me semble qu'à
la suite d'ailleurs de ce que le sénat a
proposé par la voix d'une ppl porté par
madame la sénatrice gatel faire en sorte
d'exercer un contrôle beaucoup plus
strictes sur les écoles hors contrat au
moment de leur création faire en sorte
grâce à la loi portée par monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
pouvoir avoir un contrôle beaucoup plus
strictes sur les enfants déscolarisés
sur les réseaux leur déscolarisation et
sur le contenu de l'éducation qu'ils
reçoivent à domicile
voilà à mon avis des sujets qui sont
bien plus importants bien plus porteur
que la simple évocation de la loi qui a
été évoqué voilà ma position
contre la radicalisation lutte politique
contre le communautarisme lutte à tous
les instants avec le soutien aux
enseignants avec la création des
instruments nécessaires
c'est la position du gouvernement c'est
la boussole que nous avons choisi le cap
que nous regardons 12 12 secondes
monsieur du rhin il ya ce que vous avez
dit monsieur le premier ministre il ya
aussi une forme de racisme qu'il faut
dissiper des vents mauvais souffle sur
notre société il faut dissiper la
confusion apaiser les tensions et
ramener tous nos concitoyens vers la
république la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue madame jacqueline
eustache brinio pour le groupe est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre je souhaite
vous interroger à partir de mon
expérience celle d'une élue qui a vu
progresser dans nos quartiers
le communautarisme qui a vu les jeunes
femmes se mettre le voile porté le voile
sous la pression alors que leur mère
sans été libérés le voile en 2019 n'est
pas anodin et nous aurions tort de le
considérer comme une expression d'une
pratique religieuse d'ailleurs beaucoup
de femmes musulmanes dans notre pays ne
le porte pas le voile est trop souvent
le symbole d'un islam politique qui
considèrent plus la femme comme un objet
soumis que comme un individu un individu
émancipé pour reprendre un qualificatif
cher au président de la république nous
aurions tort de baisser les yeux et ne
pas voir que le port de signes religieux
ostentatoires dans le cadre des sorties
scolaires est un instrument de
prosélytisme et parfois même de
provocation l'école de la république
doit montrer aux petites filles qu'elles
ne transige pas avec les principes de
laïcité et d'égalité
or sur cette question centrale du
respect de la laïcité et de la
neutralité régit le religieuse et
adultes intervenant dans le cas de
l'école hors les murs
la majorité et le gouvernement se divise
vous avez tenté monsieur premier mise de
désamorcer les querelles au sein de
votre majorité mais une fois de plus
vous avez en définitive baisser les bras
vous ne cessez de dire qu'il faut lutter
contre le communautarisme et en même
temps vous ne cessez de renoncer à agir
ce n'est pas l'ambiguïté qui contribuera
au réarmement moral de notre pays et au
respect des principes qui vont la france
et qui unissent les français
monsieur le premier ministre pouvait me
dire exactement ce que le gouvernement
compte faire vraiment pour lutter contre
la communautarisation de notre société
et faire respecter les principes de
notre république laïque et indivisible
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur blanc qu'est ce
qu'il vous plaît
la parole est aux ministres et à lui
seul monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
merci pour votre question qui porte sur
un sujet important sa porte déjà sur la
république je pense que nous sommes très
heureux d'avoir tous en commun
l'héritage républicain et ses skis sur
l'ensemble des bancs nous unit et
constitue notre contrat social
nous sommes aujourd'hui tous très
heureux du principe de laïcité c'est un
trésor que qui nous vient de la
république et notamment de la troisième
république
et cet héritage est un héritage
extrêmement précieux d'autant plus qu'il
est en effet un outil pour le 21e siècle
la laïcité est extrêmement moderne elle
nous est très utile dans la société
d'aujourd'hui parce que nous avons
besoin d'avoir une république une de
citoyens égaux c'est un point
extrêmement important et c'est ce qui
nous différencie d'autres pays y compris
de pays voisins
l'angleterre par exemple est une société
aujourd'hui communautariste avec les
dangers que cela représente
donc oui vous avez raison la république
et la laïcité sont nos outils
d'organisation sur le sujet particulier
que vous évoquez qui n'est pas le seul
sujet loin s'en faut
loin s'en faut en matière de laïcité et
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
cherchent un petit peu en insistez
beaucoup sur celui là alors que d'autres
sujets sont plus importants on doit
d'abord éviter la confusion
on doit d'abord éviter la confusion
j'entends dans le débat public des
choses très différentes mélanger il ya
d'abord l'action du gouvernement dans la
lutte contre la radicalisation c'est un
sujet très important sur lequel le
président de la république s'est exprimé
en des termes fermes
vous le savez il y à la lutte contre le
communautarisme et c'est ce dont je
viens de parler c'est à dire l'enjeu
républicain d'une société de citoyens
égaux et qui vaille en particulier à
l'égalité homme femme et puis il y as en
troisième lieu évidemment la laïcité qui
s'applique évidemment à toutes les
religions et qui est notre bien précieux
parce qu'elle nous permet à tous de
vivre ensemble et l'école est la matrice
de cette laïcité et nous devons à chaque
enfant
la neutralité politique et religieuse
dans sa vie quotidienne
la question des sorties scolaires est un
enjeu hybrides parce qu'il s'agit de
l'enfant en dehors de l'école mais dans
un cadre qui en est fait et scolaires et
donc je les dis nous ne souhaitons pas
une loi parce qu'une loi créerait plus
de problèmes que de solutions
autrement dit elle serait contre
active y compris vis-à-vis de notre
enjeu républicain de scolariser tous les
enfants et de faire en sorte que tous
les parents se sentent bien venu à
l'école de la république
en revanche et je les dis et c'est
l'expression le sens de l'expression que
j'ai utilisée
le voile n'est pas souhaitable parce que
en effet nous ne souhaitons pas que ce
soit un élément qui puisse être
interprété comme du prosélytisme dans
ses sorties scolaires et c'est ce que
nous sommes capables de mettre en oeuvre
concrètement tout ceci me rappelle un
adage latin qui nous vient aussi de la
république ne remarque aucune medio stat
virtus virtu vous pouvez le décrire de
deux façons c'est la vertu mais c'est
aussi le courage merci madame quelques
secondes j'ai rien entendu très concret
mais je peux pas croire qu'aujourd'hui
vous puissiez raté une occasion de
marquer une réelle volonté de lutter
contre les velléités de l'islamisme en
france alors que deux français sur trois
sont prêts à soutenir cette loi qui
interdit le voile pendant les sorties
scolaires
franchement si je trouve ça manque de
courage dernière question quand jean
louis masson pour laisser d'acteurs de
figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe il
a deux minutes s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre
par le passé les immigrés qui venait en
france voulait s'intégrer dans notre
société aujourd'hui les flux migratoires
sont différents ils conduisent à des
noyaux communautariste qui rejette notre
façon de vivre
or les terroristes musulmans trouvent
leur vivier de recrutement dans le
communautarisme radicaliser cette
radicalisation recrutent elles mêmes
dans le communautarisme ordinaire et il
est urgent de réagir
j'approuve la ministre des collectivités
territoriales qui suggère d'interdire le
port du voile islamique dans les
assemblées des collectivités
territoriales j'approuve aussi la
position du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui ne souhaitent pas que les
parents qui accompagnent les sorties
scolaires portent ce voile islamique
cependant au gouvernement d'autres
ministres disent le contraire
et soutiennent le communautarisme
islamique au risque de favoriser le
terrorisme
de son côté le payant de la république
se complaît dans l'ambiguïté monsieur le
premier ministre
oui ou non êtes-vous favorable au port
du voile islamique dans les assemblées
des collectivités territoriales oui ou
non et doux favorable au port du voile
islamique par les parents qui
accompagnent des enfants dans les écoles
pour vous répondre la parole et à la
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre porte parole du gouvernement la
ministre avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je vois que vous
êtes manifestement eu égard aux murmures
sur les bancs de cette assemblée
largement habitué à toutes les formes
d'outrance je crois qu'il est important
et le premier ministre a eu l'occasion
de le faire de rappeler au fond quels
sont les fondements de notre république
et la manière dont le fait religieux est
encadrée dans l'espace de la république
française la loi de 1905 le premier
ministre a eu l'occasion de le rappeler
fixe ce cadre et détermine le fait que
c'est en france l'état qui est laïque et
non pas la société cela signifie d'une
part que l'état laïc a un devoir de
neutralité de devoir de neutralité qui
s'incarne dans les agents de la fonction
publique c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous ne pouvons pas avoir un professeur
à l'école qui porte la kippa ou qui
portent le voile ce cadre juridique a
été complétée il y a quelques années
c'était en 2004 pour faire en sorte que
l'école en particulier soit un espace si
j'ose dire ça crée un espace de
protection qui permet aux enfants d'être
éduqué dans les valeurs de notre pays
c'est la raison pour laquelle les signes
religieux ostentatoires sont interdits
pour les élèves mineurs à l'école nous
avons également fait le choix collectif
c'était celui du législateur en 2004 de
laisser le voile autorisé pour les
parents accompagnateurs de sorties
scolaires qui sont des adultes dans la
mesure où ils ne pratiquent pas de
prosélytisme
à l'attention des élèves nous avons je
crois et le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion de le rappeler
une attitude extrêmement résolue de
lutte contre toutes les formes de
communautarisme religieux et une
attitude extrêmement ferme de lutte
contre toutes les formes de
radicalisation religieuse nous sommes
monsieur le sénateur tout aussi fermes
pour dénoncer toutes les stigmatisations
à l'attention de nos compatriotes en
raison de leur appartenance à une
religion et en particulier à la religion
musulmane je crois que nous sommes une
nation ouverte mais une nation ferme
dans ses principes qui luttent contre la
radicalité qui lutte contre le
communautarisme et le fais toujours sans
relâche
je vous remercie je me sens je devrais
je voudrais tout d'abord dire que les
gens qui viennent dans notre pays c'est
à eux deux de ceux de s'adapter à nos
règles de vie et c'est pas à nous de
subir les règles de vie de ceux qui
viennent chez nous et alors qu'on leur a
rien demandé
par ailleurs par ailleurs je voudrais
dire je voudrais dire que sur cette
affaire c'est scandaleux que par exemple
mes petits enfants vos petits-enfants
ait puissent être amenés à les faire des
visites scolaires en étant entouré par
des femmes complètement voilées mais où
est-ce qu'on en est où est ce qu'on en
est c'est scandaleux c'est la négation à
ce niveau-là de la delà de la laïcité et
moi ce que je dis faut conclure oui ce
que je veux dire juste pour conclure
c'est qu'à mon avis le conseiller
régional du rassemblement national qui a
posé le problème mériterait une
décoration il a raison
la parole est maintenant président
christian cambon pour le groupe l'est
républicain le président monsieur le
ministre
comme mes collègues précédent l'ont
souligné le le vent est à nouveau en feu
l'offensive massive que la turquie vient
de conduire dans le nord-est de la syrie
anéantie d'un seul coup tous les efforts
que la coalition avait mené coalition
dont la france est le deuxième
contributeur et tout cela risque bien
évidemment d'être un signe très positif
pour des ch qui n'en est qu'ils n'en
attendait pas tant
le bilan est accablant déjà près de
mille morts à l'heure où nous parlons
160 mille civils réfugiés lancer sur les
routes
le retour de dèche et le risque peut
être pire encore d'évasion de
djihadistes qui vont venir faire payer
très cher
l'europe pour son engagement enfin les
kurdes les cures de nos alliés les
kurdes nos amis qui se sont battus avec
temps d'héroïsme pour notre propre
sécurité
ce peuple sans patrie ce peuple trahi
une fois de plus qui est contraint
d'appeler au secours ses ennemis d'hier
les américains ont cru défendre leurs
intérêts mais quelle confiance accordera
ton demain à leur parole
alors monsieur le ministre mes questions
sont simples tout d'abord comment le
temps peut-elle rester sans réagir
nous étions un certain nombre dimanche à
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan et à
nos questions forte nous avons fait
entendre la voix de la france
le secrétaire général stoltenberg n'a
jamais daigné répondre
et par ailleurs que comptez-vous faire
face aux millions de aux milliers
d'usagers dalle de djihadistes qui
menacent notre sécurité
le ministre annonce son départ paul irak
qu espère t-il obtenir là bas et surtout
pour les français pour notre nation
que comptez-vous faire ici en france
pour assurer la sécurité des français
pour vous répondre et la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président comment
rien à redire à retrancher vous ajoutez
à au constat que vous dressez monsieur
le président ni sur le caractère
unilatéral des décisions qui ont été
prises par la turquie et les états unis
ni sur les conséquences très lourdes je
les ai évoqué mais je me retrouve
entièrement dans ce que vous avez vous
même formulée s'agissant du risque
sécuritaire du risque du risque de la
résurgence probable de dèche liés à la
déstabilisation de la possibilité de
trouver en tout cas de la très grande
difficulté de trouver une solution
politique
dès lors que cette intervention se
déroule
rien à ajouter vous évoquez au fond deux
questions distinctes même si elles sont
un peu lié la première c'est l'otan la
turquie membre de l'otan nous sommes
membres de l'otan les états unis sont
membres de l'entente un grand nombre pas
tous mais un grand nombre de partenaires
présents dans la coalition
internationale était membre de l'otan
vous avez évoqué les questions posées
par un certain nombre de parlementaires
français à l'assemblée de représentant
français à l'assemblée parlementaire de
l'otan et l'absence de réponses qu'il
aurait été formulée
cette absence de réponse me semble
traduire un très grand trouble
pour dire les choses de façon posée est
ce trouble regardons le en face
si le principe d'une alliance est de
permettre à des partenaires de
travailler ensemble les décisions
unilatérales et les décisions qui
viennent s'entrechoquer les unes avec
les autres ne me paraissent pas relever
d'un bon fonctionnement nous avons donc
là quelque chose à regarder en face à
travailler sérieusement c'est vrai avec
nos partenaires
mais quiconque consiste quiconque aurait
pour discours de dire que l'otan
fonctionne
comme elle a toujours fonctionné
circulez ya rien à voir pardon de le
dire trivialement à mon avis se
tromperait deuxième question la sécurité
en france qui se traduit de deux façons
la première c'est la possibilité de
reconstitution d'un espace géographique
maîtrisé par des cheveux qu'elle serait
propice à l'organisation d'actions à
l'extérieur de ce territoire
nous n'en sommes pas là non pas du tout
que le risque seraient nuls mais nous
n'en sommes pas là un certain nombre de
détenus sont toujours détenus ceux qui
sont en prison les prisons sont assez
loin de la zone où ont eu lieu les
combats en tout cas un certain nombre de
présidents sont très loin de la zone où
ont lieu les combats d'autres camps qui
détiennent où sont parqués si j'ose dire
non pas les combattants mais un certain
nombre de gens qui se sentent
échapperait après les derniers combats
notamment à banyuls dans le sud de la
région
ces camps sont tous encore constitué que
nous devons évidemment avoir en tête que
la résurgence de dèche est quelque chose
qui est possible et nous devons discuter
avec nos partenaires de la région qui
ont les mêmes intérêts que nous pour
savoir comment est-ce que nous allons
éviter la reconstitution de dèche cette
discussion va être compliqué car la
situation est profondément déstabilisé
et qui peut dire que nous pourrions
compter demain sur nos alliés kurdes
dans ces conditions compte tenu de la
décision américaine
et puis il ya évidemment la question des
retours vers le territoire national je
veux dire monsieur le président quand
vous que de ce point de vue là
l'ensemble du dispositif est prêt au
sens où nous sommes très à judiciariser
évidemment tous ceux qui s'étant rendus
sur zone se sont rendus complices des
actions criminelles qui ont été
conduites sur place autrement dit grande
vigilance sur le territoire
métropolitain dans l'hypothèse où
certains voudraient revenir
nous savons qu'un certain nombre de gens
s'ils devaient échapper au contrôle de
nos et les kurdes irait se battre ce ne
serait pas forcément revenir irait se
battre et travaille avec les pays
voisins notamment avec l'irak vous avez
dit monsieur le président que le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères allait se rendre
de façon imminente incessantes et même
je crois dès ce soir en irak pour
discuter avec ses homologues avec le
gouvernement irakien des mesures à
mettre en place et éventuellement de
l'accompagnement qui est susceptible
d'être mis en place notamment en matière
de coopération judiciaire
puisqu'un certain nombre de ceux qui
sont détenus en syrie par les kurdes ont
commis des crimes en irak et peuvent
donc de ce fait le cas échéant être
judiciariser sur place c'est un des
éléments qui sera évoquée par le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères avec son homologue sont avec
son homologue iranien
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à notre collègue rémi féraud
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues ma question
porte à nouveau sur l'agression
militaire de la turquie dans le nord-est
syrien ce que nous demandons est je
crois dans l'ensemble des groupes de
cette assemblée à votre gouvernement
c'est de réagir plus fortement plus
fermement plus rapidement il en va de la
fidélité à nos alliés kurde bien sûr de
la fidélité à nos valeurs mais aussi de
notre propre sécurité
comme le premier ministre vient de le
dire lui-même chacun sait le rôle
exceptionnel des combattants kurdes aux
côtés de la coalition internationale
dans l'éradication du califat de dèche
chacun sait que les attaquer aujourd'hui
c'est permettre laser la résurgence du
terrorisme islamiste jusque sur notre
sol le président de la république a
appelé la société française à faire bloc
contre le terrorisme or cette lutte elle
est globale et faire bloc en france sera
illusoire si nous laissons et
djihadistes reprendre pied dans le
nord-est syrien alors vous nous dites
que la france agit et c'est vrai mais
nous vous disons qu'elle agit trop tard
et insuffisamment pour être efficaces
ces sondes intériorisé un sentiment
d'impuissance et d'isolement largement
exagéré l' invasion par la turquie du
canton dafri nhs livrer ensuite aux
milices aux djihadistes et où les kurdes
ont été victimes d'un véritable
nettoyage ethnique était un
avertissement auquel nous n'avons pas su
réagir
alors monsieur le ministre
la france va-t-elle enfin se mobiliser à
la hauteur des sacrifices réalisés pour
nous par les combattants kurdes
merci je le mois de monsieur le ministre
répondre merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur rémi
féraud oui vous avez raison le rôle joué
par les combattants des forces
démocratiques syriennes les fds dont les
kurdes a été déterminant et ils y sont
ils sont parvenus à une défaite
territoriale de dèche avec l'appui de la
coalition internationale de la france et
le courage de ces femmes et de ces
hommes appellent notre reconnaissance
une reconnaissance qui doit continuer à
s'exprimer
naturellement dans les faits est ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que il n'ya pas
de dosage dans la façon dont nous
justement cherchons à mobiliser tout le
monde
notre engagement il est total pour
mobiliser la communauté internationale
encore une fois dans toutes les
enceintes nous avons immédiatement
appelé à la réunion du conseil de
sécurité dès lors que l'armée turque
avait franchi cette frontière
nous avons nous n'avons pas ménagé notre
peine parce que très clairement la
décision les décisions unilatérales qui
évoque l prémunissent qui ont été prises
sont graves très graves et leurs auteurs
portent une responsabilité devant
l'histoire naturellement alors monsieur
le sénateur je vous sais très impliquée
sur la question kurde
à l'image de la haute assemblée de la
commission des affaires étrangères qui
ce matin a auditionné l'ambassadeur de
turquie
je veux saluer d'ailleurs la proposition
de résolution qui appelle un engagement
résolu de la france en faveur de toute
initiative
sachez que nous rejoignons complètement
cet appel que c est en ce moment même
discutée lors du conseil des ministres
franco allemand qui se réunit
à toulouse que les prochaines heures les
prochains jours seront également très
important au conseil européen et que la
situation humanitaire étant ce qu'elle
est eh bien nous nous préparons d'ores
et déjà à une réponse avec notre centre
recrue de crise et de soutien parce que
l'afflux de réfugiés risquent de se
faire au kurdistan irakien
il ya d'ailleurs une demande d' aide
internationale pour pouvoir gérer cette
situation et nous devrons être également
présent au rendez-vous pour ses frères
d'armes de lutte contre le terrorisme
que sont les kurdes monsieur féraud
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre de votre
réponse nous appelons les autorités
françaises à s'engager davantage et à
sortir de la posture défensive dans
laquelle nous nous sommes nous mêmes
placés rappelons la phrase de charb
contre le cynisme et la mort aujourd'hui
il y a le peuple kurde
il est de notre devoir est de notre
intérêt d'être à ses côtés
nous serons à vos côtés pour prendre des
initiatives beaucoup plus forte dans les
jours qui viennent
merci
[Applaudissements]